je vous ai tous invités à ce prime et
vous avez une invitation un petit peu
particulière sachez le
puisque pour ce prime refait l'année on
voulait marquer le coup et on voulait
que les invitations symbolise s'est
passé dans l'année regardez la première
partie de cette remise invitation avec
les invitations de mathieu kelly et
jean-michel regard johnny blaze
[Musique]
à
le bassin
alors amo o'kelly pour résumer cette
saison c'est pas très original mais
j'irai d'arc à cette saison ça a été je
pensais mais la meilleure pas pour moi
et pour toute l'équipe
on s'est jamais autant marrer un mot
pour résumer cette saison alors je
dirais de leur mort mais parce que c'est
celui qui a été une fois de plus meyer
qui a le plus donné de bonheur aux gens
c'est délicat quand même remporté le
trophée du meilleur chroniqueur qui ça
comme quoi maxime gainey s'est calmée
homme politique c'est toujours quand on
disparaît qu'on remonte dans les
sondages meilleur souvenir peut-être la
laponie
il faisait un froid de canard moi
j'avais une diarrhée de ouf de yesh
derrière un arbre avec des rennes
c'était plutôt un souvenir original donc
j'ai une amie lorsque j'ai refait la
chorégraphie d' jeanne mas première
conversion très chocolat pas y croire je
ne peux pas le croire mais je vous crois
même pas invitation sera là bas c'est le
chauffeur
j'aurais dit frej rue de fraises
mon pire souvenir la première fois qu'on
s'est pris du chocolat dans la bataille
bassiri je t'emmerde
voilà mais cette fois ci bien profonde
te le dis je t'aime quand même tu en as
valet par les bombes à 4,2 mois
[Musique]
les invitations de benjamin castaldi
valérie benaïm et maxime qui dit et on a
isolé ensuite doc gynéco soir la
demi-finale aller voir doc gynéco c'est
incroyable c'est le seul mec qui prend
du chocolat mais il continue d'une
interview comme suit dans la verrais
bien dans un instant on l'est en regard
des benjamins valérie maxime
[Musique]
k
m
mais bon ça
on va revenir un peu sur la saison on
revient sur les nerfs soutenir les pires
souvenirs
oui n'entend gala comme le mit qui
pensent qu' avoir la crainte de la perte
alors pour toi en un mot comment tu peux
résumer cette saison valait un mot
formidable délires verbaux c'est pour se
marier pendant trois heures c'est
formidable pour mesdames je suis
tellement pas serein théorique gebauer
où il tombe bien souvient son frigo
c'est lorsque du public est venu chanter
pour céline je crois que c'est un fou
rire que j'ai eu avec cyril avait même
quitté les plateaux de lingerie pour
qu'un souvenir nantais ppc quoi est ce
qu'on a vraiment des pires souvenirs
peut-être la première fois qu'on a pris
du chocolat dans la fille s'est bien
passé on a fait pas mal bavé en fin de
saison
c'est peut-être un peu difficile à vivre
sur le moment mais en regardant les
images comme très très drôle
[Musique]
si on t'aime salopiots des regrets ou
pas non à zéro regret à part peut-être
le chocolat le voir son habitation
allez vous faire [ __ ] mais ses sorties
12.2 ton cul je ne savais bande de
connards du match à pau doit-on tu dois
te laisser encore une idée tallulah ça
j'en peux plus j'avoue je peux plus te
voir cyril je ne peux plus te voir
bon ben tu pas envie de vous dire merci
vous êtes là dedans mais c'est vous qui
comprenait plus à chaque fois c'est fait
mais je sais pas si c'est moi pourquoi
il ya un truc vraiment je suis toujours
dans le dans laxe et y en a qui n'a
toujours pas compris qu'il avait pris du
chocolat c'est dans le gynéco à chaque
fois il reste tranquille une évolution
continue the show must go et regarder
pour lui ne plus aborder ce n'est pas le
chocolat c'est cette interview qui les
claques
nous répondons que si l'on regarde
[Musique]
le
le médecin
comment tu peux résumer en un mot son
arrivée sur tlt en un seul mot bien je
suis arrivé hier
[Musique]
avec adjectif qualificatif c'est à dire
et comme bien nouveau comme un nouveau
casque écrit sur des fiches beaucoup de
différentes données beaucoup de choses
que je note un peu ce qui se passe que
je peux plus ou moins comprendre de la
situation pour pouvoir m'adapter
j'arrive à faire un peu le numéro 10
cachet à ce poste de numéro 10 caché
dans l imaginaire ou pas oui c'est qui
[Musique]
mais tu ne parles pour son plateau alors
là cette année la nouveauté de cyril et
s'amuser c'est beaucoup beaucoup amusé
avec vous cette année avec quelque chose
qui est tout surpris
est ce que t'as kiffé chocolat ou pas
ouais j'aime beaucoup ça c'est
intéressant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez je veux le revoir on veut le
revoir
allez-y alors on est en train de le
recaler au magnétoscope beaucoup
beaucoup amusé avec vous cette année
avec quelques shoots tout surtout si
elles sont taxées chocolat
[Applaudissements]